were in the tournaments maybe he was
aware that his air quality was affecting
him maybe feeling a bit stuffy in that
room oh and it was the English opening
and I was expecting you to guess that
one Kaya and so close I did get it right
there was no E4 D4 or Knight F3 he
starts with the pawn in front of the
bishop and moves it two steps ahead but
we might see a conversion there yeah so
a transposition it started as an English
opening it can transpose into the
Queen's gun but declined especially if
white lifts his Queen spawn now we're
back in the Queen's Gambit declined via
a different route in the twitch chat we
will pay attention to that as well thank
you for being with us on this big day in
the Champions chess store and let's have
some fun I feel like we've said our
favorite Pokemon Magnus and car do the
same in the chat probably has to get
involved with that we're talking about
Chess but Pokemon has been a theme
throughout the event definitely yeah so
this is a known variation but I haven't
known Hikaru to dabble in this one too
much normally he chooses a very solid
approach there we see Magnus push upon
fluid so the Queen's Gambit accepted
it's a kind of branch of that now showed
Hikaru grabbing a pawn he's given a pawn
back but not the typical Pawn that you
would see black offer in most variations
here black has really ugly structure on
the queen side doubled C pawns isolated
a pawn but he has a really juicy Outpost
for his Knight in the middle of the
board and whoever races out gets
developed first tends to get the
advantage here I've always slightly
preferred White's chances you get more
space you have the more fluid structure
but black as Tania said very Dynamic and
Hikaru clearly choosing this opening
because of the match situation is part
of his strategy to imbalance things and
maybe even go for a win as black uh
Robert what do you think of this uh of
this plan has these doubled isolated
pawns on the sea file we see the one
next to the queen and the one sticking
out pretty far on the C4 square that
said as David was matching the D5 square
is firmly under Black's control there's
not a white Pawn that can challenge the
square and Black's light Square Bishop
will slide onto the fin Kettle diagonal
and take control over the board's
longest line so this is going to be good
news for Hikari and Castle queenside his
King will be safe there despite the
advanced pawns and that D4 Pawn is a bit
tender in White's position double edge
position chances for both yep definitely
chances for both but if this one does
start to turn around hikaru's turning
things in his favor then Magnus might
start to get nervous a loss with white
and the whole momentum the whole
initiative of the match would change so
Magnus here just developing his Queen
both sides staying very very flexible
white can also look at certain Pawn
breaks on the queen side with moving
that beep on one step ahead and Magnus
stops it forever with his La hecaro
stops it forever with his last move he
jumps the Knight forward the one
weakness that white had created with
that eight push is the B3 square that is
where the Knight has headed we've been
talking about not making intentions
clear with the black king and look at
hikaru's uh last move there is no Queen
side castling anymore Hikaru is going
for the attack for the initiative along
the b-file so this does mean that both
sides may be intend to Castle on the
king side and uh we'll see if either
side can attack that flank later and you
were mentioning about clearing the way
one possible plan for black to do that
is Step Up with the bishop do that C6
Square uh David and then you want to
bring your knight let's see if he can
bring up the analysis board in a bit but
it's a very nice idea
um really interesting starts and uh yeah
did you expect this Robert I must admit
I thought Hikaru would just try and hold
with black and press with white but he
hasn't been pressing hard with white so
far this tournament and wow I think
we're both shot by this last minute yeah
you asked me expectations I wasn't quite
expecting the pawn push it does make
sense you're just saying are you sure
you want to Castle kingside for Hikaru
because New Castle there white is going
to launch an attack ready to bring the
fight to Magnus and he plays tiniest
move Bishop C6 and the Knight May slide
out next as we're showing in some
previous lines uh but perhaps Magnus
Carlson is going to take a page out of
uh was it gukesh's book sliding his King
one square over instead of castling he
will lift his Rook later but for now he
might just slide his King to the side
and I was he prepared this line and look
at Magnus he's saying all
steam ahead let's go push that pawn
forward H5 maybe that pump will go for
it even further to H6 just try try to
create a dent in Black's king-size
structure and very often with these top
players uh in chess we see that their
moves make sense when you look at them
backwards the plan that Hikaru shown on
the queen side and we were talking about
the Knight jumping onto A4 to clear the
b-file but Hikaru has something else in
mind he decides to force a trade-off and
create an imbalance by exchanging the
bishop for the Knight normally you want
to strand your opponent's Knights on the
side of the board especially when you
have strong Bishops as white does but uh
Robert predicts it correctly you can
allow a queen trade but on your own
terms there the Black Knights would have
actually been surprisingly strong oh wow
predicted it before we've got two
profits here in the studio Tanya and
Robert and the Knight has jumped in
hitting this Rook if the Rook moves like
does have the opportunity to slide back
second time we've seen this and as
Tanya's also mentioning The Rook moves
the Night Moves Like B3 on the board
David and well it's a start the kind of
position that he's gotten it's extremely
Dynamic now he gives a check he gives
the check doesn't fall back with the
Knight and look at the way he's playing
such aggressive moves every move is a
piece forward just incredible stuff he
is taking significant risks however he's
playing very aggressively but he has
abandoned his King side and Magnus takes
the opportunity to step forward now
watch out in any end game that y H Pawn
is very close to promotion the number of
times I've seen Magnus promote his AO
pawns after marching them forward uh
this far and only now does Magnus
clarify the central tension a decent
share of the chances okay he's gone for
this line so we might well see after
Bishop takes one Magnus just recapture
just go oppon up and threats against the
black king let's see whether he finds a
solution Magnus didn't take that pawn
yet surprising I've got to say but uh
still looks like a decent position he
trades off Bishops instead and there we
go he beat me to it I was about to say
normally having a non-costal king is a
problem because your Rooks aren't
connected but here it doesn't matter
White's Rook is able to get up the board
and start attacking across and very
effective where if black defends it with
the third piece and I see that Hikaru is
reaching out for his Mouse he's about to
make a move then white can't pick up the
C4 Pawn with the bishop you pick it up
with the Knight and the Knight on B3
hangs so he would have lost the pawn
anywhere and instead Hikaru decides to
First bring his King to safety but the
big question always in this position is
how safe is that King pinning the bishop
but can the Knight be picked up on B3 I
think it can and it most likely will and
uh the only question here for Magnus is
which way do you capture you could take
this Knight with your queen allowing the
Black Knight to jump in and this is a
superior version of what we looked at
earlier for black because suddenly both
your Rooks are active suddenly all of
your pieces really really well placed
and uh okay looks like we've gone in the
other direction sorry just to backtrack
after Bishop takes I was expecting Queen
takes Queen here I've got to say I'm
heading into an end game but white would
have had an extra Pawn instead Hikaru
gives a really sneaky check hitting the
white king just in time Magnus is able
to go and block with his Queen his Queen
was also Under Fire and now the bishop
Falls and this is the current position
White's the report up but with those
pieces on the board and we just see The
magnus's Rook slide across the B4
hitting the queen protecting that extra
pawn and that pawn is ultra well
defended and now magnets continue to
improve his other pieces watch out for
hikaru's King but for now he is quite
active trying to create threats against
the White Queen side that's bad news for
the black king So Hikaru lashes out with
his Pawn push to A5 look at how quickly
though Magnus is responding and a card
needs to have his moves ready quickly
because he's down under a minute on the
clock and he remains a pawn down on the
board the more hopeless it feels David
and we've been discussing all these
mating ideas and Magnus steps up with
this queen to the center of the board
I got the feeling that because of the
mating Nets that we've been showing the
king the black king just caged up on the
king side Hikaru might not have any
better choice than to offer a queen
trade but the end game is no better for
him and uh you predicted it correctly
Tanya and you're right it's no better
for him still just insurmountable
problems it feels like with the black
king on the back rank maybe if the black
king was closer to the center again an
active King in the end game uh he would
have some chances but this one I already
see some trouble there's some variations
here which I think will land on the
board Magnus is happy to just trade one
set of Rooks because that black Rook is
stuck not about Pawn quantity I mean
that's not the only thing that matters
the piece quality is the more important
element of this position that's why a
car didn't even take the pawn he
understood that his Knight would have
actually been trapped on B2 you see the
Knight has nowhere back to go The Rook
has to stay in the last rank otherwise
there's a Checkmate that gives white a
free hand on the king side or in the
center of the board just to trap that
Knight and go ahead and win at least a
pawn and maybe more yeah and now again
Magnus has that luxury of the move okay
he brings his Rook to the seventh rank
as Robert points out this Pawn is the
first Target it's gonna be the first one
that drops at some point Magnus will
happily just activate his King the
Knight will always be trapped if it ever
gets greedy and wow Hikaru decides to go
for it I think there were no better
options this Knight now stuck in no
man's land and even if you don't trap it
just go on the attack there we go Magnus
Carlson tying down look how passive
these pieces are now he can reroute his
Knight into this juicy F6 square and the
king is going to be stuck in the corner
as a bystander for the rest of the game
he has that we're discussing for Magnus
right now really rely on that E5 bond
which is why we see magnus's last move
he comes back with the Rook to take away
that key Square for the Knight and
Hikaru is Shifting back to the open file
again threatening the night jump from B2
to C4 okay some tricks at least some
hope of Salvation if you get your knight
back into the game I'm wondering now how
Magnus proceeds uh your right handy
actually not as easy as it looks at
first glance
still feels like it must be winning
somehow but some work to be done magnets
will have to go for and Hikari let's see
Rook F4 here come the moves here they
are all going and the white king goes up
well look at Hikaru go he's just chasing
the King around trying to force it to a
sub-optimal square but the F7 Pawn at
the end of the day that Still Remains a
Target and a car down just 11 seconds
and it should be the end and he's going
for it he kind of drops back very clever
defensive move yet again what a champion
he is holding on here for dear life in
the twitch chat saying Psyduck versus
hikachu
that is amazing and okay shifting Focus
now White's threatening to deliver a
nasty check a mating threat there on the
back rank which Hikaru blocks yet again
it feels like Magnus is throwing
everything at Hikaru but Hikaru is
always swatting it away he always has an
answer and suddenly the Black Knight is
threatening to porn simultaneously
Magnus takes one but okay it does feel
like Hikaru is slightly closer to saving
this game now especially if he can go
and capture that white H Pawn that thorn
in his side and it's heading that that's
exactly what he does he moves that
Knight attacking that H Pawn but you can
pick up the F7 Pawn currently because if
you pick it up with the Knight then you
don't win that eight six Pawn so white
does have that option Magnus goes for it
picking up a pawn defending his own and
I'm expecting Hikaru to move the Rook
along the f file and what what happened
he saw enough time but barely enough
time and that's the problem is the
Knight is kicked out it's the white
knight defends the pawn the Black Knight
can't stay there forever and don't
forget that white has his past Pawn on
the queen said that A3 Pawn still exists
you're gonna start pushing that one up
the board and threading the black king
with checkmating ideas Hikaru looks very
unhappy with his position shaking his
head there he looked ready to resign he
nearly got out of his chair a moment ago
now Magnus has to be slightly careful
where he puts the king you don't want to
put the King on a passive Square there
we go out into the open out towards
safety and I think uh Hikaru body
language he's ready to resign the white
King's just going to attack these pieces
and now the black king is the one that
is doomed Checkmate is coming Black's
King all alone and Hikaru does
eventually throw in the towel wow Magnus
Carlson strikes first in the Grand Final
he
detained with the white pieces that
means sikara Nakamura will have to make
a comeback at some point and take this
to a grand final minus looking over this